I don't know how else to say it.
Every week.
Public support for impeaching Donald Trump
is going up.
Reasonable question.
David, why do we give a, you know, what about
this, why do we care about this?
The reason we care is that if there's any
chance that Republicans will turn on Donald
Trump, it's going to be based on public opinion
about impeachment.
For better or worse, we can say this is terrible,
that this is the reality, but this is the
reality.
Republicans are putting their fingers to the
wind and to the extent that public opinion
shifts in favor of impeaching and removing
Donald Trump, that is the only remotely possible
way that you are going to see Republicans
say, you know what?
Maybe it is time for the president to go.
It's not likely, but we do have some historical
precedent for it.
If you go back to the 1970s and Richard Nixon,
this was admittedly, historically a very different
circumstance.
Public support for Nixon's removal was a really
big piece of Republican's eventually going
to Nixon and saying, listen, we don't want
to impeach you to convict you on impeachment,
but we sort of are going to have to, it would
be much better if you resigned.
And ultimately Nixon did resign.
And that's why this is relevant.
So let's look at the numbers for Donald Trump.
Multiple new polls about this.
None of them good for Trump.
A new Quinnipiac poll says 55% have registered
repo, a registered voters support the impeachment
inquiry.
That's up four points from a week ago, which
was up from 46 the week before, which was
up from like the high thirties the week before
that.
So the trend is very, very clear.
48% support, not just the inquiry, but the
removal of the president of the United States.
That's roughly half of the country on the
question of whether Trump's dealings with
Ukraine, uh, were all to further his personal
interest.
59% say yes.
They were also up from previous numbers.
Also not good for Donald Trump, by the way,
as a leading indicator to further future support
for impeachment.
Now on that one, the question to me is why
do 59% it's not a question of why 59% realized
the truth about Trump's dealing with Ukraine.
It's what is preventing the other 41% from
realizing that obviously Donald Trump's interactions
with Ukraine were out of personal interests,
like what is holding back that 41% from realizing
what's right in front of their faces.
Also, from the Quinnipiac university poll,
58% of independent support, the inquiry, 49%
say remove Trump from office, which is absolutely
stunning.
We have a new Reuters Ipsos poll, which shows
that among independent voters, impeachment
support is up.
It's not just Democrats who want Trump impeached.
Uh, that one says that overall, 48% of the
country wants Trump impeached and removed
in line with the first poll that we looked
at.
And then you have a new CNN poll, which says
50% of Americans want Trump removed.
Also very high.
Now we can quibble about the specific numbers
in the margins for error.
One says 48 ones is 49 one says 51 as a margin
for error of error of three.
The CNN poll a famously has a margin of error
of five, which makes it on the border of being
statistically significant.
But somewhere around, if you look at all the
polls on average, somewhere around one and
two Americans believe that Donald Trump should
be impeached and removed from office.
And that's a number that's climbing weekly.
This is not normal.
That's the important thing to understand.
This was not the case under Barack Obama.
Republicans hated the guy.
Republicans talked about impeaching Obama.
They didn't because they wouldn't have been
able to.
There was nothing to impeach him over.
Uh, and there was no public demand for the
impeachment of Barack Obama.
When you look at these numbers and understand
the hyperpartisan environment that exists
today, 59% of the country agreeing on anything
is stunning.
That's why 88% agreeing on universal firearms
purchase background checks after Sandy hook
was so huge and still our elected officials
just couldn't get it done.
So these impeachment numbers are massive.
Remember that the public hearings haven't
even started yet.
It's all just been meetings and requests for
documents so far.
My guesses that the public hearings will very
heavily trigger Donald Trump's Twitter rampages,
which don't seem to be helping him lately.
So we're just at the beginning of this thing.
The concern though is we are now only, what
is it, 53 weeks, 54 weeks from the 2020 election,
and if this is going to damage Trump, it's
got to get going before Trump's reelection
campaign really gets going in earnest and
takes over the new cycle.
That's where we are right now.
Let me know what you think.
Leave a comment.
If you're watching on YouTube, send me a tweet.
If you're on Twitter at [inaudible] Pacman